over sabbath there was a hostage
situation at a synagogue in a place
called colleyville which is near dallas
texas and it started with an islamist
radical going into
this synagogue and demanding the freeing
of a terrorist
and it ended with all of the hostages
freed and the terrorists shot dead the
hostage taker shot dead which is the way
all these situations should end and god
bless the folks from swat who put this
guy down and thank god that nobody
innocent was injured in this process
well according to the local paper the
fourth star telegram the fbi on sunday
identified the hostage taker in the
standoff at a colleyville synagogue as a
44 year old british citizen by british
citizen they mean the guy is a radical
muslim from britain
i don't do the names of terrorists on
this program i don't do the names of
mass shooters on this program because
they are looking for notoriety so we do
not provide that but this guy was a
radical islamist he could be heard
speaking during a live stream that
broadcast a portion of the 11 hour
standoff died saturday night after a
hostage rescue team breached the
building the four hostages were unarmed
authorities said saturday that the
hostage taker was killed in the shooting
did not answer a question about whether
he was shot by law enforcement or if the
gunshot was self-inflicted the man
claimed to have explosives according to
statements he made on live stream videos
president biden did call this an act of
terror he said there were apparently no
explosives
this
particular person was demanding the
freeing
of a woman who is a terrorist i mean
she's been in prison she's gonna be in
prison for the next several decades
before this facebook's live stream was
taken offline about 2pm an angry man
could be heard ranting at times talking
about religion i love the the star
telegrams description of this ranting
about judaism in islam would be the
answer to this
the hostage taker apparently was
singularly focused on one issue he
repeatedly mentioned his sister and
islam and used profanities hilariously
everybody was like well he's not
actually sisters with the terrorists yes
i know
okay in religious communities
particularly islamic religious
communities this is just true in
religious communities all over the place
people sometimes call each other brother
and sister it's not like it doesn't mean
they're literally brother and sister
he apparently said once i have my sister
here let me tell you i will not take
these four guys out i swear by allah
so islam is radical trying to free a a
terrorist this person was trying to free
a person named afiyah siddiqui a
pakistani neuroscientist who attracted
the attention of american law
enforcement in the years after the
september 11th attacks
top fbi and justice department described
her as an al-qaeda operative and
facilitator at an a 2004 news conference
in which they warned of intelligence
showing that al-qaeda plans an attack in
the coming months for years supporters
have called for the release of siddiki
she was a neuroscientist who's an mit
graduate she's currently being held at a
women's prison in fort worth she was
convicted in 2010 on charges related to
the attempted murder and assault of u.s
officers and employees in afghanistan
two years earlier the hostage taker said
a few times he didn't want anyone heard
he mentioned his own kids he said
repeatedly he believed he was going to
die a couple of his kids were just
arrested
in great britain
this person was apparently from the
blackburn area of lancashire
a rabbi with the simon wiesenthal center
said in a statement sunday they believed
the hostage taker was able to enter the
synagogue by posing as a homeless man
and this was a a synagogue so they said
okay come on in and then it turns out
that he was in fact a hostage taker now
what is amazing about this particular
situation is that it is not particularly
surprising the reason that is not
particularly surprising and the reason
that synagogues all over the united
states have security is because there
are a lot of people who target jews
because they are anti-semites because
they hate jews it is not a giant giant
shock and this particular hostage taking
shouldn't have been
supremely surprising at least over the
issue of afiya siddiqui because this has
been a caused celeb in the islamist
community for a very very long time as
well as among left-wing allies
national review had a piece
by sam westrop in september titled
islamists exploit western progressives
handwringing to support their own
said siddiqui was known as lady al-qaeda
and is supposedly a victim of the
security state's cruelty siddiqui earned
the moniker in 2004 after the fbi named
her as one of seven senior al-qaeda
figures plotting attacks against the
united states fbi director robert
mueller described her at the time as an
al-qaeda operative and facilitator years
later siddiqui was captured in
afghanistan upon her arrest
investigators found handwritten notes
that referred to a mass casualty attack
and that listed various locations in the
united states including plum island the
empire state building the statue of
liberty wall street and the brooklyn
bridge other notes in siddiqui's
possession referred to the construction
of dirty bombs and discussed various
ways to attack enemies including by
destroying reconnaissance drones using
underwater bombs and deploying gliders
in the lead-up to her trial siddiqui who
hated jews demanded the jews be excluded
from the jury claimed claiming the
entire prosecution had been orchestrated
by unnamed jews she was sentenced in
2010 to 86 years in prison after the
jury found that siddiqui attempted to
murder americans serving in afghanistan
as well as their afghan colleagues
since her conviction a bunch of jihadist
groups have demanded her release
apparently the taliban offered to
exchange siddiqui for captured u.s army
sergeant beau bergdahl isis also offered
to exchange prisoners as did al qaeda
indeed the pakistani regime has long
been a leading voice in the cultural
release of siddiqui with tacit support
from elements of the regime for jihadist
group such as the taliban and yaishi
mohammed
siddiqi was linked to both groups
pakistani prime minister yusuf gaza
giladi once referred to siddiqui as
daughter of the nation
siddiqui was a beacon to islamists
everywhere european jihadist tied
charitable on convoys to syria named
vehicles after her in 2018 one jihadist
even attempted an attack on the federal
medical center carswell in fort worth
and an attempt to free her so this is
not even the last time
this is not the first time that somebody
has attempted to free lady al-qaeda
by by engaging in violent action
a wide variety of lawful american
islamist groups and clerics many of whom
have grown increasingly close to
pakistan over the past decade also now
campaign on siddiqui's behalf
this includes a bunch of major american
islamist organizations
okay so this has been sort of a cause
celeb among left-wing advocates as well
as islamist advocates for quite a while
in the united states
and yet the narrative in the middle of
this particular hostage-taking is that
we had no clue what was happening and in
fact anybody who suggested this might
have to do with the innate anti-semitism
of islamism
is uh is is somehow islamophobic now
this is a bizarre contention because i
was
actually texting with a muslim friend of
mine on saturday night and he was saying
that he was praying obviously for the
freeing of the jews who'd been taken
hostage because it turns out that a huge
number of muslims are not in favor of
people taking jews hostage in order to
free terrorists i know shocker shocked
there are many muslims who are not in
favor of this but
for a very wide swath of the left-wing
media and for many of the muslim voices
promoted by the mainstream media the
idea that this has anything to do with
islamism which is a which is a radical
form of islam that unfortunately has
many adherents around the world that if
you mention this sort of stuff this
makes you an islamophobe
no
it does not
and one of the people who was pushing
the left-wing perspective was wajahat
ali who used to be on cnn he tweeted
you're about to hear some ugly and
vicious islamophobia and anti-muslim
bigotry this weekend from elected
officials commentators and even
mainstream media hope i'm wrong people
will use it to divide jewish and muslim
communities for their political agenda
don't fall for it yes whenever jews are
taken hostage by a radical muslim the
real victims are muslims
obviously islamophobia is obviously the
thing we ought to worry about and this
has been a pattern in american public
life with regard to a wide variety of
crimes for a very long time if you are
identified by the left in the united
states as a victim group if a member of
that supposed victim group perpetrates a
crime we are supposed to pretend that it
is not a crime or that it is a mystery
we've had the same thing happening with
regard to anti-semitism for years in new
york and new jersey when a black hebrew
israelite attempted to murder a bunch of
jewish children in new jersey now she
did kill some people in new jersey it
was treated as a non-national story for
more than about 25 seconds when a white
supremacist targets jews at the tree of
life synagogue in pittsburgh that's a
national story because there you have a
member of a quote unquote not victimized
group attacking jews or a more
victimized group therefore the
intersectional hierarchy has been upheld
the victimized group was victimized the
victimizing group was the victimizer and
therefore that is a newsworthy story
however it is not newsworthy when a poor
black person attacks a jew in
williamsburg
if that happens that is not a story and
if a muslim attacks a jew that's also
not a story because according to the
left for some odd reason radical muslims
attacking jews
is somehow
a story of the victimized group
attacking the victimizing group now just
on a pure kind of global power level you
have to question why that would possibly
be the case
there are well over a billion muslims on
planet earth there are grand total at
current of like 15 million jews on the
planet
muslims are in control of some 57 58
countries on planet earth jews are in
control of one
a jews are a minority in every country
except for israel muslims are a majority
in a wide variety of countries
and yet somehow according to the left
whenever there is a conflict between jew
and muslim it must be the jews who are
the perpetrators and if it's the reverse
then we have to pretend that it's not
happening or we have to downplay it we
have to pretend it's some sort of enigma
wrapped in a mystery
again this has nothing to do with the
idea that all muslims are anti-semitic
or all muslims are
are terrorists or anything remotely like
that that's not true
what it does have to do with is the
left's willingness to cover up crimes
because it does not back the narrative
that they wish to purvey which is that
in the intersectional hierarchy jews are
the victimizers when posited next to
muslims and this also has to do by the
way with the with the wild anti-israel
sentiment on the left that has now
cropped up
you know the the there are a lot of
people who wonder why is it that the
left is so radically anti-israel these
days considering that israel is
significantly more in line with a lot of
the social views of the left than the
muslim world is
in israel famously you can live openly
as a gay person in israel
in israel women have tremendous amounts
of rights israel is very liberal with
regard to women's rights israel has very
liberal abortion law you would figure
that the left would be very much in
favor of israel and yet not so why well
because essentially leftism is now a
class conspiracy theory whereby anybody
who is successful violated somebody who
is unsuccessful which is how they got
successful well that theory sounds a lot
like anti-semitic conspiracy theories
about jews in control of the media using
controls of world finance jews in
control of the power centers and
therefore jews must have victimized
somebody in order to achieve their power
the leftist narrative as applied to jews
more specifically is the same as the
anti-semitic narrative which is why
there is this stream crossing and why we
have to the minute that jews are taken
hostage at a a dallas synagogue
a huge part of the media is immediately
like this is gonna be about islamophobia
isn't it it's gonna be this is why the
democratic party when ilhan omar who's a
radical anti-semite when she says a
bunch of jew-hating crap this is why the
democratic party immediately has to pass
a resolution condemning both
anti-semitism and islamophobia as the
one can't be condemned without
condemning the other
it's absurd and unfortunately this has
bled up into the major institutions of
american life and anti-semitism can only
be taken seriously by the left when the
person who is purveying the
anti-semitism is a white person that is
the only time it is worth noting
which of course is bizarre since the
vast majority of anti-semitism pervaded
on planet earth right now is not
pervaded by white people
i hate to break it to folks but that is
not the case hey white
if there are white supremacists they're
incredibly dangerous okay they're white
supremacists who hate jews they're
incredibly dangerous i know this
personally because the fbi arrested a
white supremacist about four years ago
who was targeting my family and that
person is now in jail
okay so i i get it
but the vast majority of anti-semitism
on planet earth right now is not being
purveyed by white supremacists because
that's a very small number of white
supremacists the vast majority of of
anti-semitism in terms of hate crime in
terms of action in terms of broad policy
that is being purveyed is being purveyed
by radical muslims
or in domestic context it's being
pervaded by people of color okay this is
true in new york
but you can't you can't pay attention to
that because anti-semitism only matters
when the people who are promoting the
anti-semitism are people that the left
has decided are members of the power
class the response from the federal
government the immediate response was
bewildering to say the least the fbi
came out and they made a statement see
if you can spot the problem with this
particular
statement we do believe from our
engagement with this subject that he was
singularly focused on one issue
and it was not specifically related to
the jewish community uh but we're
continuing to work to find motive and we
will continue on that path what did it
have to do with the jewish community
what are they
it's part of a broader anti-semitic
conspiracy theory held by radical
muslims the jews are in control of all
the levers of power lady al-qaeda
literally said it at her trial she
literally said the jews are behind this
so is it a giant shock that a radical
islamist decided to invade a synagogue
and hold jews at gunpoint saying that
somehow they had the magical weather
controlling power to free terrorists
i mean
it's not a surprise in any sort of way
but we have to pretend that we don't
know
by the way it doesn't just apply to jews
this sort of logic remember that the
military for years denied that the fort
hood massacre which was carried out by a
radical islamist that that had anything
to do with radical islam they said it
was sort of they called it a workplace
violence incident
because for the left any time there's a
member of a victimized population who
commits a crime
we cannot we cannot acknowledge the
hatred implicit therein
because to do so would recognize that
sometimes the quote-unquote victimizing
group is actually the victim group and
we can't ever ever have that okay joe
biden did some of the same stuff he said
well you know we kind of know why he's
targeted at the synagogue but at the
same time then he buys it back because
this is what joe biden does
well no i don't we don't have i don't
think there is
sufficient information to know about
uh
why he
targeted that synagogue why he insisted
on the release of someone who's been in
prison for over uh 10 years why he was
engaged why he
was using anti-semitic and anti-israeli
comments uh i i we just don't have
enough facts we don't have enough facts
i'm how about he's a radical islamist
that's that's the only fact you need
which is
true i think that's it
done but he can't acknowledge that right
why is it so tough to look no i i don't
know honestly i don't understand this if
it had been a white supremacist who had
gone into a synagogue and shot a bunch
of people do you think joe biden would
be there like we don't know enough to
know his motive he'd just say he's a
white supremacist of course he was there
to shoot jews like what why why is that
in any way a mystery but somehow again
it always comes back to the narrative
always in forever and then joe biden
turned and swiveled and he blamed guns
or something which is i'm sorry come on
come on the guy bought the gun illegally
by the way as joe biden acknowledges
shabbat acknowledges this guy literally
bought the gun off the street he didn't
walk into a gun shop and then buy it
just over the counter
the idea of background checks are
critical but you can't stop something
like this if someone is on the street
buying something from somebody else on
the street
except that there's two there's so many
guns that have been sold of late it's
just ridiculous and uh and it's because
of the failure us to focus as hard as we
should and as consistently should
on gun purchases gun sales ghost guns a
whole range of things that i'm trying to
do okay that would have nothing to do
with uh stopping what happened
in uh in
colleyville like that that's that's a
that's a that's a ridiculous ridiculous
statement by joe biden again he does not
want to acknowledge the reality
meanwhile the new york times didn't even
put this on their front page so the new
york times front page the day after has
a lot of stories
including
a woman killed after a shove in the
subway and vladimir putin could cause
trouble not just in ukraine but in the
west but uh nothing on the front page
about the the attempt to kill four jews
uh in in dallas after a 12 hour standoff
no nothing nothing there
kind of kind of amazing do you think for
white supremacists that might have made
the front page maybe just a little bit
now what's amazing about all of this
from a jewish perspective you know as an
orthodox jew and someone's deeply
encountered in the jewish community one
of the things that is perfectly obvious
from all of this is that there are so
many jews there's a commentary to some
of my jewish brothers and sisters there
are a lot of jews who think that by
dissociating from the jewish community
or who think that by ripping on israel
that somehow they're going to buy the
love of anti-semites all over the world
i'm not saying that you have to take a
wildly right-wing position on the same
issues that i do i'm not saying you have
to mirror my perspectives all i'm saying
is that for anti-semites a jew is a jew
is a jew and it does not matter how much
you say that israel is bad or a
quote-unquote apartheid immigration no
matter how much you fib about that or
lie about that no matter how much you
attempt to buy the love of of leftists
who supposedly will treat you decently
the minute that you are victimized by
somebody who is higher than you on the
totem of intersectionality on the totem
pole of intersection now the minute that
happens you become baggage
this particular congregation is a very
far-left congregation politically
speaking but it's a reformed
congregation the rabbi at this
congregation is guy named charlie
citroen walker
and he's a very progressive dude
according to forward.com
he was he was a person who was
constantly holding iftar dinners and he
arrived at beth israel in 2006 shortly
after his ordination from hebrew union
college jewish institute of religion he
was this he was the small reformed
congregation's first full-time rabbi he
is the kind of person who took his
wife's name as like a hyphenated name
he's a very
left-leaning guy for sure and his wife
works for a group called the
multicultural alliance the couple has
two daughters the younger of whom became
bat mitzvah during the pandemic before
starting rabbinical school he worked at
focus hope a civil and human rights
organization in detroit and at a soup
kitchen and food pantry in amherst
massachusetts
and there there's a lot of talk about
his his positions with regard to israel
which are extremely progressive
and this is not to say that he has to
hold the same position that i do he
certainly does not there's a lot of
diversity in the jewish community about
this sort of stuff no matter how much i
think that that certain perspectives are
wrong and in some cases even anti-judaic
the point that's not the point i'm
making the point that i'm making is when
it comes to anti-semites they do not
care anti-semites don't care neither
does the left it wasn't like joe biden
was like well he attacked a progressive
jewish synagogue therefore
this is anti-semitism and and we should
and we should really pay attention to
the deep levels of anti-semitism that
paint all jews with the same brush et
cetera et cetera
there is not a lot of that there's not a
lot of that and the reason there's not a
lot of that is because two anti-semites
all jews are the same when it comes to
the intersectional pyramid which is
rooted in identity politics all jews are
the same as well
the reform jews the same as the orthodox
jew the pro-israel jews the same as the
anti-israel jew they're all the same
because again when it comes to which
group is a victimized group and which
group is a victimizing group which is
the only question that matters from the
progressive left jews are the
victimizing group
they somehow moved from being the
victimized group to the victimizing
group when they became wildly successful
and highly educated and when israel
became a successful state in the middle
east when that happened all sympathy
went out the window for all of this and
so it won't be on the front page anymore
it won't be on the front page this is
something by the way that the jews have
been lamenting for quite a while again
their jew the rate of hate crimes
against jews in 2020 2021 in new york
city was astonishing
and bill de blasio had said he didn't
even know what was happening he didn't
know what's happening because the people
doing it weren't wearing maga caps
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang